[Music]
Uh
Yes Hello, let's distribute an open source library.
My name is Ieumsae.
I was born and raised in Korea, and then
moved to Singapore at the end of
2016.  I live
in France and I work for a company called Algoria.
Algoria is a cloud service provider that provides search functions as a cloud service, and
provides all exit kits for developers to add search functions to their websites or apps.  To
briefly talk about the overall stack of Ria, there is
back & such as the infrastructure engine database, and there
is a
rest api on top of it.  api clients are provided
php movie javascript python kotlin .net catch ghoul ang
scala ios android api clients are provided for quite a variety of languages
and on top of that javascript api client I developed something called instant installation,
a kind of javascript  You can see it as a component library.
Now, instead of directly calling the search api using an api client
and directly displaying the results, if you
just bring and attach the components we provide, the website or app is a
function that is complete.  For example, there are components such as a search bar or filter pagination,
etc. So, I am working on this instant installation of the JavaScript component library library, and
I am working as a member of this team.  Since I
did the point j, I am developing a vanilla js library.
Also, I am
developing an instant installation with a total of 4 flavors like the view angler above.
And I
am developing and painting many other libraries.
Uh, coding is probably what everyone loves.  At least,
I don't know how many people listening to this announcement say that they hate coding.
Everyone does coding at work, and many people
do side projects at home on the weekend after work, and everyone will like it.
A lot of people like it,
especially testing is the same as tdd, and there are many other things, but
there are people who are very passionate and passionate about it,
and they like debugging itself.  There is
such joy when it is released, so it
seems that a lot of people like it until testing and debugging.
By the way, does
anyone
like cannon? I
like distribution. Well, I like cannon so much.
I don't think I've ever heard of this kind of thing. In particular, it
seems to get a little worse when I finish distributing the library.
Well,
before talking about distributing the library for a month, I
'll talk about app distribution for a moment.
To distribute the app, many people  You
use a lot of cd services in Ceci. To
name just a few examples, on lexi dolls, pen 2
chamkin, etc., there are now many ci real services, and they are
distributing using these tools a lot.  Because of this, I
think app distribution is a good thing,
but I think library distribution in particular is a little less enjoyable.
Why? There are many reasons.
It could be. Unlike an app, if a library
encounters a bug, even if the fix is ​​redistributed, the
user has to update the library, so it's a step further than the app, so I
think there are a lot of worries about bugs,
but now  I can't help you with that part.
Worrying about bugs can be solved only if you don't create a bug thread.
To do that, you have to write the code well, and you
need to write a good test case to catch the error.  You have to
set up a system that monitors certain errors and this section so that you can catch them well, and now you have to do those kinds of things, but
that's completely out of scope for my presentation, so
I can't help you with that.  Uh,
then I think I'll worry a lot about mistakes.
There are a lot of mistakes, for example, using the wrong node js version. There are a
lot of nude version managers.  If you
go back and forth,
it seems that there are definitely problems that arise from trying to deploy with the wrong node
version.  If you do it
100% by omitting the baby distant 7 called dash dash tag beta when
distributing it, it
will be a very big mistake to throw away what will be distributed as a sweet beta version to stable distribution.
I don't know what kind of sensibility you have about this,
but I don't think I've done anything wrong, but things like that get twisted for no reason.
If there is a problem, there is a
problem of waiting yes.
If you run lint and run unitest and even ntn test, etc., you
have to wait until it is finished.  You
can think of it as something less than the Chen test,
but the problem is that it takes less than 4 minutes and 30 seconds, but you can think that it
takes only 5 to 10 seconds while waiting for this.  If you
press and go to Twitter and go to
Twitter for 10 to 15 minutes, then go back after saying “yes” and then go back, then
situations like that that have already ended a long time ago
often occur.  If you
wait again, there will be time to
run the same mullint or tests as before to do the distribution in your face branch.
During that time, there
is a risk to move to another branch and do other development work.  It's safe to just leave the base branch as it is, and
there's a risk of something going wrong,
so it seems like there's a lot of time to wait without doing anything.  The
first number is major, then the minor patch.
So, when distributing a library, it is important to decide what time the next version will be, but the
convention  According to
uh, then there is a 2p called Conventional Comedy. There is a
website called Conventional
Commit.  It
means that the part after the colon
is now actually describing the contents of that commit. Again,
or now the sex parentheses open, the compiler closes with , and
this kind of apocalypse 2 compiler part is called scoop,
so in other words, this com
fixed something  It's a commit, but its scope is the compiler,
so it's a computer that fixes something related to the compiler. You can understand it this way, and transcends. This means
chores.  It must be such a commit that does not
affect the version of Ox again. This com also updated the version, the version affects the update, the version does
not affect the version.
And in the case of this commit message, breaking change is entered in capital letters, but it is a
convention that says that it would be better to update the major version because there is a breaking change literally written by a com with such a blanking change.
Coming messages are
all commits that require a patch update.
Also, a new feature is added to the city. In this case,
it is a minor update.  The
sional coming message has been influenced by the Emblem team and has continued to
develop. It is
used in various places now, such as
bj s web pack angular lux sp z
etc. It is used in a number of open source libraries, and many companies also use it.
If you've
seen a change log file that looks like this, you'll most likely
see it as 8 generated by a tool called Conventional Change Log.
Once you see what a conventional change tool is doing,  Let's follow it.
Now, the
most recent distribution was this 0 point 15.0 version.
And in that sense, it's a new 108 com.
Likewise, even if you get 2 seconds, it becomes such a commit message that the combat conventional change log is ignored and passed on.
So, as a result, these 3
com efforts include chain hell.  I went in and
this went in like this, and the introduction and forgetting light went into a section called s. As you
can see, the scope called my la
was included in bold. And you can also see that a minor update was made because a new feature was added.
Another thing to pay attention to
is the baby mount called the tag like 4 o'clock.
Well, depending on the case, it
can be
distributed with tags such as canary rc,
etc.  There is a case like this. I
think this is a very easy part to forget that it is important to
take a good look at.  So,
when you deploy it, you run it.
Then, if you run this, the script does a
small application, cleaner, darker, and
checks to see if there is any work that needs to be committed.
Then, the package is in the chase.  Update the version,
update it with the change log, and of course kick com ride the changes,
run the test, build,
mpm publicity, or pour the tag beta like a dash.
The process that I explained all along yesterday is contained in the die script, so I just had to
run it as it is, so there was no problem.
I forgot the file in the install jsl pystory.
In fact, this is also in React 4, 8 Story,
View, and Angler,
but they are all slightly different.
I can make mistakes due to the reasons I listed earlier. That's
why I'm still nervous, and every time I study distribution, I'm
just nervous, so I call a colleague to sit in front of my computer and do it together,
and still the tests are successful.  If so,
what kind of alternatives are there? Well, I'll
tell you about two alternatives.
First of all, there is a
tool called np.  And those who have been making a lot of such software actively, and
ent is literally
a tool that is about a better version of uh mpm public c.
Publicity and push tags
5 It
is almost unified with the script I had,
but now one problem is that when I try to distribute it, I always
ask for the next version like
this.
The problem that you have to wait until it's all over still
exists.
Oh, looking at another alternative, there is another famous tool called
Smenty Ring.
Uh, when you run this tool, you
go through efi conditions, tolerant free rides, cray kitek fpl wifi, and these colors.
Actually, there is no part of Tomei TV, No. 2 Tomei, because of the body's personality,
so there is no time for me to get involved.  I
thought that a different process would be needed.
So, after thinking about it, I
split the process into three steps.
The first is the pre-pair, the second, the always review, and the
third is the trigger. It is divided into three steps.  The
next version is now easy to get because the commit message is convention.
Then go to a temporary branch and
check it out. For example, check out the current checkup recipe.
It updates the version
and the change log is also updated. Take
that change to your computer and make a precast. Now, this is the
first cart.
Then what is the second part? It's simple.  There will
be various factors when doing it, but there must be a
status check. You must have seen
a lot of these screens.  There may be this, but you
can also do it using tools such as code raw box eye or pika ci. To
briefly explain the code sandbox eye, if you
link the accord box eye to 1 4 8 stories, you will get a
comment like this every time you make a flea cast.  will run by itself.
Then this full cast will temporarily distribute the current state to this branch.
So, this temporary fish oil is created, and with this, you can install it in any environment and
manually test what you want to test, or any
customer  You
can check if this version works well by sending it to.
Also, since it is a box eye that uses coordination, it provides a sandal box using this version,
so if you make a template in advance, you can easily test it.
Then, if there is something wrong  Then, you can add a commit to that branch.
For example, simply change the change log a little bit.
Then, you can modify Chen Zhou and do the pulley cast fc.
Then, as a result, if you skip the full cast  If you
press the earth squash m1 c button like this, a new commit will be added
Transcend coulon release version 1.2 2.3 A new coming
message like this will be added
Then now the third process
is the trigger The new commit will trigger ci and cd
For example  For example, there must be something like circle ci or choi bsci.
Then that ci will run a script. What that script does is mpm run bill
mpm publicity.
Okay, I'll
do a review again. Update the version, update the change log,
kick commit, and test build
publicity right. There's a whole process like this. Here's part one,
here's part
two and three parts.  It's broken into new steps.
Hey, you can wait a little less in the new process,
because hey, out of 3 parts, your computer will
run only part one.
Well it
takes less than a minute to run uh uh you make fewer mistakes
because uh 2 whole process
you only have to run party one and
part two apartment three is not your responsibility
what else
As long as it's not reviewed in Gitub, there won't be any problems with the review, and
circus eye won't suddenly stop working, and now you can separate these responsibilities
so you just have to run part one, and
the rest of the well-organized process.  Therefore, it is okay to say the word Gap. Because of
that, there is a tendency to be a little less nervous.
Also, when you run part-to-part, you will return to Part-to-Party, and you
can review alone, but you can also review together with
colleagues or community members.  It will be a way to relieve some nervous tension in that you can review it like this.
Then you can completely automate part one and part three.
Well, that's why I created a tool called Easy Jesus.
Like this, the cross es is part one
uh easy sp repair uh yea it's the command you run.
[Music] It's
easy as is easy. We've been using Jesus to distribute it. It's
a little bit confusing,
but in fact, it's
natural.  I'm going to show you
0.2 10 Cheop 20.0
100 I tried to update from the version called 0.2 10.0 to the stable version called 0.2 10.0
Now I took a picture of the process.  I'm going to
date with a point. I'm
going to run the command on the command line. As you can
see, the release is supposed to run a command called the actual esp pair.  It's
easy as to make a suggestion that it won't be peg top 5,
but we don't because that's not the case.
Enter the version. Then, create a staging branch,
update the version and change log, and make a pulley cast under it.
It will
automatically run the ugg flea cast to the browser.
So if you look at it, various information is well summarized. If you
look at these and the review is finished, you can do something square.
Now, just ignore it and do something.  You
can do this in practice. You have to wait until the end, get the erf water, and know what it is.
Then, since a new commit has been added to Hulk ci, a new
task is running.
Now, take a quick look at this task.  I'm using circle ci, but if you
look at the comp p article,
there's a release, so you go to the task called d, and when a new addition is made to the branch called main, that
task is executed.
So, um, Serkis Ai prepares for something, and then if you
run the yang uh easy st thing, you can see that Ian field is done, published to mpm, and
tags are created and the play is
done until the play is given.
So mpm  If you refresh in , you
can see that the new version 0.2 10.0 has been added. It has
been distributed as a mat stack like this.
When you execute the command 2, a
cli that sets up your 8 stories appears, so you
can use it easily, and you
can use it as well as the bilingual action.
Also, the
documentation is well written so that you can try various settings on how the overall settings are.
Uh, so far, with the help of so many contributors, I was able to develop as easily. The
story of the second phrase written in Chapter 10  No,
this is a story about a process.
Hey, this is a story about a new process to improve a process that I was uncomfortable with, and a
tool to support the process.  I hope you
try to apply it. You
can steal it as much as you want, just let me
know. I just want to hear what you do
because I'm
curious.  Come in and I'll be on Twitter anytime you can find Under Squall #1 and it's
easy to find Under Squall #4 under the revision my Jesus.
Thank you.